[Musique]
j'étais chez en 2005 français et je lui
ai donné la carte vitale et vu que je
suis élu s'il m'a demandé tu es content
que ce que tu as fait
qu'est ce que ton président a fait et
c'était la deuxième jour le délégué et
c'était juste la première question il
m'a pas demandé qu'est ce que c'est quoi
ton problème pourquoi tu es venu ici il
m'a demandé mais était content qu est-ce
que ton président sait qu'en ce moment
c'est la chasse aux sorcières vraiment
on a trouvé un ennemi c'est la russie
est donc tous les russes maintenant vous
êtes russe ça veut dire que vous êtes un
ami e s et ça concerne pas que la france
je pense que c'est concernant toute
l'europe malheureusement ce que nous
voyons direct du monde donc ce qu ils
vivent est impossible ne pas remarquer
c'est donc une vraie sous les
eaux ou vraie hystérie anti russe je
pense qu'on vit mal ceux qui ont un peu
de coeur évidemment ils vivent mal après
le problème c'est que ils sont pas plus
malheureux que ceux qui sont sous la
bombe 1 et 2 ils sont quand même bien
mieux que ceux qui sont à moscou et qui
risque elle risque 15 ans de prison pour
pour dire une phrase de travers donc on
n'est vraiment pas à plaindre nous les
russes à paris